welcome to the Elder Scrolls legends a
strategy card game featuring creatures
characters and more from across the
history of the Elder Scrolls each battle
begins with a hand of three cars when
it's your turn you draw one card and
gain one magica needed to play your
cards place a card on one of two sides
called lanes some lanes have special
conditions that alter the field of that
choose to attack a card in the same Lane
or attack your opponent directly you win
when your opponent is out of health take
enough damage and one of your runes will
shatter each time this happens you will
immediately draw a card that could
change your fortunes
your choices and a little luck can tip
the scales from defeat to victory battle
anytime or anywhere on your own or
against other players test your might in
a full campaign in quick skirmishes or
in the arena where you'll face a
gauntlet of foes
build your collection of allies
armaments and magic combine your cards
to create powerful decks train your
cards to increase their power
choose your strategy
choose your path choose your destiny and
become
a legend